Let's formalize this a little bit.
What we've been working with
is something called a Markov
decision problem.
And here's what makes up
a Markov decision problem.
There are a set of states S.
Those are all the values that this S
can take as it comes into the robot.
There's a set of actions A,
which is these potential actions we
can take to act on the environment.
There's a transition function.
This is the T within the environment.
And this is a little bit complicated,
but let's just step through it.
T is a three-dimensional object,
and it records in each of its cells
the probability that if
we are in state S and
we take action A,
we will end up in state S prime.
Something to note about this transition
function is, suppose we're in state,
a particular state S and
we take a particular action A.
The sum of all the next states we
might end up in has to sum to one.
In other words, with probability one,
we're going to end up in some new state,
but the distribution of probabilities
across these different states is what
makes this informative and revealing.
Finally, an important component
of Markov decision problems
is the reward function.
And that's what gives us the reward.
If we're in a particular state and
we take an action A,
we get a particular reward.
So if we have all of
these things defined,
we have what's called
a Markov decision problem.
Now, the problem for a reinforcement
learning algorithm is to find
this policy pi that will
maximize reward over time.
And, in fact,
if it finds the optimal policy,
we give it a little symbol pi starred
to indicate that it's optimal.
Now, if we have these, and,
in particular, if we have T and
R, there are algorithms we can unleash
that will find this optimal policy.
Two of them are policy iteration and
value iteration.
Now, in this class, we don't
start off knowing T and R, and so
we're not going to be able to use these
algorithms directly to find this policy.